welcome to the presentation on level
four linear equations so let's start
doing some problems
so let's say i had the situation uh let
me make up a problem if i said 3
over x
is equal to
let's just say 5.
so what we want to do this this problem
is a little unusual from everything
we've ever seen because here instead of
having x in the numerator we actually
have x in the denominator so
i personally don't like having x's in my
denominator so we want to get outside of
the denominator or into a numerator or
at least not in the denominator as soon
as possible
so one way to get a number out of the
denominator is if we were to multiply
both sides of this equation by x
you see that on the left hand side of
the equation these two x's will cancel
out and on the right side you'll just
get 5 times x
so this equals
the two x's cancel out and you get 3 is
equal to
5x
now we could also write that as
5x is equal to 3
and then we can think about this two
ways we either just multiply both sides
by one-fifth
or you could just view that as dividing
by five
if you multiply both sides by one-fifth
the left-hand side becomes x
and the right-hand side three times
one-fifths is equal to three-fifths
so what did we do here this is just like
this actually turns into a level two
problem or actually a level one problem
very quickly all we had to do is
multiply both sides of this equation by
x and we got the x's out of the
denominator let's do another problem
let's have
hmm
let me say
x
plus 2
over
x
plus 1
is equal to
say
7.
so here instead of having just an x in
the denominator we have a whole x plus 1
in the denominator but we're going to do
it the same way
to get that x plus 1
out of the denominator we multiply both
sides of this equation times x plus 1
over 1
times this side since we did it on the
left hand side we also have to do it on
the right hand side and this is just 7
over 1 times x plus one
over one
on the left hand side the x plus ones
cancel out and you're just left with
x
plus two it's over one but we can just
ignore the one and then that equals
seven
times x plus one
and that's the same thing as x plus two
and remember it's seven times the whole
thing x plus one so we actually have to
use the distributive property and that
equals
seven
x
plus
seven
so now it's turned into a i think this
is a level three linear equation and now
all we do is we say well let's get all
the x's on one hand one side of the
equation and let's get all the constant
terms like the 2 and the 7 on the other
side of the equation so i'm going to
choose to get the x's on the left so
let's bring that 7x on to the left and
we can do that by subtracting 7x from
both sides
minus 7x plus it's a minus 7x
the right-hand side these two 7x's will
cancel out
and on the left-hand side we have minus
7x
plus x well that's minus
6x
plus 2
is equal to and on the right all we have
left is seven
now we just have to get rid of this two
and we can just do that by subtracting
two from both sides
and we're left with
minus six x
is equal to
five
now it's a level one problem we just
have to multiply both sides times the
reciprocal of the coefficient on the
left hand side and the coefficients
negative six so we multiply both sides
of this equation by negative 1 over 6
negative 1 over 6.
the right the left-hand side negative 1
over 6 times negative 6 well that just
equals 1 so we just get x
is equal to
5 times negative 1 6 well that's
negative
over 6
and we're done and if you wanted to
check it you could just take that x
equals negative 5 6 and put it back in
the original equation to confirm that it
worked let's do another one
and i'm making these up on the fly so i
apologize
let me think
times
x
plus five
is equal to
eight
times x plus two
well we do the same thing here
although now we have two expressions
that we want to get out of the
denominators we want to get this x plus
5 out and we want to get this x plus 2
out so let's do the x plus 5 first well
just like we did before we multiply both
sides of this equation by x plus 5 you
could say x plus 5 over 1
times x plus 5.
over 1.
on the left hand side they get canceled
out so we're left with
is equal to
8 times x plus 5
all of that over x
plus 2.
on the now on the on the top just to
simplify it we once again just multiply
that 8 times the whole expression so
it's 8x
plus
over x plus 2.
now we want to get rid of this x plus 2
and we can do it the same way we can
multiply both sides of this equation by
x plus 2
over 1
x plus two we could just say we're
multiplying both sides by x plus two
that one is a little unnecessary
so the left hand side becomes
three
x
plus six remember always distribute
three times because you're multiplying
it times the whole expression x plus two
and on the right hand side well this x
plus two and this x plus two will cancel
out and we're left with eight x
plus forty and this is now a level three
problem
well if we subtract 8x from both sides
minus 8x plus i think i'm running out of
space
minus 8x well on the right hand side the
8x's cancel out on the left-hand side we
have minus 5
x
plus
is equal to on the right hand side all
we have left is 40.
now we can subtract 6 from both sides of
this equation let me just write it out
here minus 6 plus minus 6.
now i'm going to hope i don't lose you
guys by trying to go up here
but if we subtract minus 6 from both
sides on the left hand side we're just
left with
minus
five
x
equals and on the right hand side we
have thirty-four
now it's a level one problem we just
multiply both sides times negative
one-fifth
times negative one-fifth
left-hand side we have x
and then the right-hand side we have
negative 34
over five
unless i made some careless mistakes i
think that's right and i think if you uh
if you understood what we just did here
you're ready to tackle some level four
linear equations have fun